/ dear / dear are we rolling oh great
okay hey everyone I'm a Bashar welcome
to Abby's kitchen and another edition of
the ridiculous where I cover all the
most insane health and wellness trends
and products on the worldwide web so
first on our ridiculous is his goddess
vaginal detox pearl hmm sounds expensive
and it is because it's $33 for a fake
pearl now according to the CEO
apparently any time a woman has sex with
a man he imprints his energy onto her
womb and this vaginal detox pearl is
able to kind of suck that bad juju out
using vibrational energy now this pearl
claims to reduce menstrual cramps
increased libido kill parasites remove
toxins and ultimately detox you from
your ex I mean I bet there's a lot of
ladies out there who are signing up
right now
okay so this is what they call the
process using a land Keys method and
this is trademarked actually this old
land keys method so day 1 will include
leaving the goddess vaginal detox pearl
in for 24 hours day two to three believe
the goddess vaginal detox pearl in for
48 hours oh my god then day 3 to 6 is
the purging phase we're dead vaginal
skin cells mucus yeast old blood clots
among other components are expelled from
the vaginal area sounds delicious and I
mean what can we expect I'm just reading
some of these awesome glowing reviews
she says it's a game changer sex was way
more exciting as I was able to get more
fluid than usual I was even able to
squirt now as tempting as that sounds
ladies let's just break it down for a
hot minute here because we're not
putting like anything into our room
which is what this woman is suggesting
we're detoxing we're not putting
anything on to our womb unless maybe our
OB is doing it or there's like some
crazy long applicator going on
that sounds very uncomfortable because
our cervix protects our womb hell no so
I have no idea how it's supposed to cast
suck that energy out of the womb or why
there's any man's and
jee-in there anyway second of all the
CEO actually recommends that you put
this pearl up inside you and leave it
there for 24 hours hmm now thanks to a
lot of mom talks some sex education and
Judy Blume novels that you don't want
anything up in your vajayjay for like 24
hours or 48 hours honestly the only
thing I would expect to get out of this
pearl is like toxic shock syndrome and
my 13 year old self is terrified pass so
next on ridiculous are these Helio Care
sunscreen pills now these apparently are
supposed to protect your skin from UV
rays thanks to their potent antioxidant
content oh and bonus they are vegan and
gluten-free which seems to be the
selling point for like all of these
holistic supplements now for 60 capsules
you're gonna pay $13 and honestly I
don't even know why these things exist
now the best part about these is in the
fine print they actually recommend their
use with regular sunscreen applications
ah no [ __ ] Sherlock
this is dangerous stuff the FDA has
actually even stepped in with a warning
about this product to prevent people
from using this as their sole form of
protection from the Sun yes these pills
do contain the active ingredient called
poly podium Lukic homeless extract which
one study found that taken orally may
help reduce the damaging effects of UV
rays however this is one study and
clearly for a lot of people this is
likely not going to be enough in terms
of protecting them from the Sun you
cannot just pop a pill and expect
yourself to be protected from the very
very very damaging effects of UVA and
UVB rays please protect yourself from
the Sun put on sunscreen put a
long-sleeve shirt on stay out of the Sun
during those really hot hours of the day
and please just save your money and skip
the sun protection pills
next I'm a pale [ __ ] and I need
sunscreen Purdy or Purdy I'm gonna make
you less and party prettier placenta
where do they get that all right
next folks is Purdy or placenta I'm
loving that Purdy looking really pretty
with this placenta supplement so this is
apparently made out of deer placenta
there's 12 active ingredients including
lots of vitamins and minerals some fatty
acids antioxidants and collagen peptides
of course so what can deer placenta do
for you Wow according to this guy a lot
so we're looking at things like
anti-aging immunity and perfect guttin
digestive health the usual suspects but
this company takes it even farther and
suggest that it helps couples conceive
through IVF dangerous don't go there
and may even cure your cancer in ms wow
this is insane from a deer's placenta so
one bottle it's going to cost you three
hundred and eighty dollars for deer
placenta so let's talk about the
evidence here so the whole idea of
consuming your placenta is super trendy
but also really controversial and
potentially dangerous I mean we're
talking about things like bacterial
contamination and heavy metal
contamination as well now yes of course
there are advances happening when it
comes to stem cell research and we
definitely need to keep an eye on that
however the claims made by this company
are baseless and downright dangerous
in fact some countries have actually
issued a warning against these products
so I say it protects your health and
your wallet and skip the deer placenta
imagine filling up a neti pot for a hot
minute feeling a little bit of us I have
a little congestion happening you're
just gonna clear things up with
something this fresh pee
all right and last but not least let's
talk about urine therapy
so you've probably always thought that
the only interaction that you and your
piss had was what you look down at in
the toilet but some people now are
practicing selling we call urine therapy
which is basically when an individual
drinks moisturizes massages or clears
their sinuses with their pee now let's
just imagine for a hot minute that you
had a nice steak dinner with a side of
broiled asparagus and then you're
feeling a little bit of a little
congestion happening so you decide to
put your fresh warm asparagus scented
pea into the neti pot and give it a good
rinse how disgusting is that honestly
let's take a look at some claims here so
some people say that you're in therapy
can cure chronic diseases of course
reset the immune system hmm
promote weight loss somehow good health
and even improve our skin the only way I
can see this helping with weight loss is
if you like solely you've only up a
urine cleanse and you're like just
drinking urine all day and the thought
of that just makes me want to die now
the only benefit I can see that this
whole urine therapy in my ridiculous
series is that it doesn't cost you
anything I mean you're just peeing
anyway so you get this cleanse for free
it's not like those green juice cleanses
that you're spending a hundred bucks a
day on so bonus so let's talk about the
evidence or lack thereof of course a lot
of doctors are urging know they are like
bagging their patients to stop drinking
their urine because it's essentially a
waste product I mean there's a reason
your body got rid of it in the first
place mmm-hmm not to mention once it
leaves your body it can be contaminated
with bacteria and of course leads to
illness and there is no research to
support the idea that drinking your
urine is going to improve your health in
any way so please by the love of all
that is holy leave the piss in the
toilet and drink a glass of water okay
and on that note I got to use the
washroom but I'm gonna close things off
here and ask all of you to please
leave me a comment below with any
totally ridiculous products or wellness
trends or ideas that you've been hearing
things that you've seen up on the
internet leave me a comment below with
those ideas I would love to talk about
them in a future episode give this
episode a thumbs up thumbs up if you
liked it subscribe to the channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]